from a game that featured the current
goat and the future goat at quarterback
to a game that literally had goats
playing quarterback all due respect to
the quarterbacks involved what's the
saying if you have two quarterbacks you
have none i got a ch i got a twist if
you have no quarterbacks you have none
right and that's what the broncos had
because of the covet 19 protocols very
simple situation jeff driscoll tested
positive last week and is part of the
contact tracing as part of the analysis
and this is actually something that the
broncos
self-reported they saw surveillance
video from the quarterback room they saw
that the quarterbacks were gathered
there it was an approved meeting now
some are mobilizing to blame the broncos
for everything and say it was an
unsanctioned meeting i'm told it was an
approved meeting it's in writing it was
approved but at some point during that
meeting an issue with the masks broncos
saw it on the video they sent it to the
league
some 30 hours later the broncos found
out
you don't get to have any of your
quarterbacks tomorrow they found out
just before practice on saturday
they're doing a walk through they're
finalizing everything oh sorry
your your other three quarterbacks not
named draft driscoll you know your
starter drew lock and his backups
they're out they're gone you got to find
somebody else to play quarterback
tomorrow and we're not bending and at
that point
i'm surprised the line only went to 15.
i'm so i'm shocked that it wasn't 20 or
25 when you have kendall hinton a
practice squad receiver who got beat out
for the quarterback job at wake forest
once we knew he was playing with one day
to prepare for it going against one of
the best defenses in the nfl
of course they're going to get blown off
the field and they did they did i mean
that was insane to watch first off i
mean it really was yeah you
denver fought hard their defense kind of
kept them in there for the first quarter
or whatever but there's only so much
they can do i mean when you're back on
the field every fourth play eventually
you're gonna wear down as the lesser
football team but i mean this is the the
great example mike and this is why i
like we we've talked about it so much
this is hey players
you gotta compete with yourself this
year even when you're out of the
facility all the time or in the facility
whatever it is you just got to be on the
ball all the time to make sure you're
available to play football and yeah the
quarterbacks in denver got careless you
know and they they're the ones that gave
this team the loss i'm not saying they
would have won if drew locke was out
there or whatever but they gave them the
loss by being careless inside the
meeting rooms breaking protocols it
stinks i understand everybody gets
relaxed every now and then but this is
the way the world is right now and you
get a big l for that
a couple of points real quickly can we
put the graphic back up kendall hinton
first quarterback with more
interceptions than completion since 1998
it was the first game since tim tebow's
broadcast of 2011 where the quarterback
had no completions at all in the first
half and it reminds me of the nathan
peterman stat line from a few years ago
when he was playing for the bills
against the chargers yeah when
when when you took his numbers
and you ran them through the passer
rating calculator as if he was intending
to throw the ball
to chargers players he had a higher
passer rating than he did while
intending to throw the ball to bill's
players that's how bad it was that day
for peterman but at least peterman knew
he was going to play quarterback that
day and had been drafted to be a
quarterback hinton undrafted as a
receiver gets thrust into it i felt
badly for him for a while it looked like
it was going to be royce freeman phillip
lindsey took several snaps at
quarterback until he got injured and it
was a mess here's vic fangio to your
point though talking about his own
disappointment in the behavior of his
quarterbacks that resulted in them
abruptly being told thou shalt not play
on sunday
well i was disappointed um
on a couple levels in that
that our quarterbacks put us in this
position that it put our quarterbacks
put the league in that position
you know there's there we count on them
to be the leaders of the team and
you know leaders of the offense and
those guys made a mistake
and that that is disappointing
there's tension between the league and
the teams as it relates to
the league's plans for dealing with the
pandemic right and the team's execution
of the plan and i've noticed a trend
this year and i know there are some
coaches around the league who aren't
happy about this anytime there's an
issue
the league aggressively blames the team
blames the players and piles on and i
think the broncos even though fancio
was a company man not broncos company
but nfl incorporated company man saying
what he said i know there's some
frustration about how
the league
jumped on them and blamed them and
ultimately refused to give them a day or
two to get their quarterbacks back and
postpone the game but look the nfl made
it clear chris in october to all the
teams competitive concerns
do not matter yeah you are going to be
expected to play if you have no
quarterbacks if you have no linemen if
you have no kickers if you have no
anything if you have no coaches whatever
it may be you better figure it out and
you better be ready to go because it's
on you if you have guys on the covet 19
reserve list and and you you believe
that you can't field a competitive team
we don't care if it's not competitive
you just have to field a team because
we've got 256 boxes to check this year
and we're putting a check mark in that
damn box for this game i know unless
there's an uncontained outbreak that's
the difference because people still
can't understand because the league
really hasn't come out and said it
the baltimore game got postponed twice
and could be postponed still a third
time
because of an outbreak that has not been
fully contained if it's just this guy's
positive and this guy's a close contact
so he's automatically out and this guy's
a positive and these guys are both then
we're we're still going forward with the
game yeah i i didn't i i know and i get
that but this is where i get frustrated
as an ex-football player this is where
it really pisses me off for lack of a
better way to say it all players players
coaches do right do right you did wrong
you did wrong oh wait there's kind of a
start of an outbreak in baltimore well
it's a big thursday night game hold on
you guys can go in the facility one more
day it's okay one more day oh it's okay
for you oh it was okay for you guys to
bend the rules and fudge them oh okay
oh but then you're gonna throw out and
be like the hammer when a player or a
coach has a mask down a little bit that
to me is where i go blah blah blah shut
the hell up nfl
well well
but but look that's one of the reasons
why the outbreak happened they had every
reason to know as of sunday night that
that you know they had they had done the
tracing i think they knew by sunday
night that they had the well the
strength coach had already tested
positive and i think any time you have a
strength and conditioning coach who
tests positive that is red alert sound
the alarm yes
that guy interacts with everybody and
then and so they knew it was coming
and and and that's that's what was
stunning to me that they were allowed to
practice and be in the facility monday
and tuesday because they they wanted to
get that thursday night game in and it
was only on tuesday when they got more
indications of additional positives they
said we just we we can't do this and
frankly chris and we'll talk more about
the raven situation coming up
i still am not sure this game's going
forward i'm starting to get the sense
that there are two camps in the league
office there is the damn the torpedoes
camp and there is the
science over football camp safety over
checking the box camp and i don't know
who's going to win but that's still
churning and the evidence is still
rolling in every day with more positives
or not
and uh so so i i i'm still not 100 sure
the game's going to happen i think that
there there's starting to be some
wavering i believe on the part of the
medical people the question is can they
get others
who have final say over whether or not
the game will be played to waver as well
and push this to what would be the first
game of the 18th week of the season
which the nfl is trying desperately to
avoid
you know we haven't been together since
wednesday a lot's happened since then
but the nfl is trying to desperately
avoid putting any game at week 18
because then for the remainder of the
season
for the ravens and the steelers you have
no wiggle room for them or for the teams
they may be playing right you can't put
another game involving either team in
week 18. so that automatically becomes
the first game that is gone for good
yeah yeah that's scary and you're right
you don't you don't really think about
the ripple effect sometimes in that and
you're trying to not
you know go to the danger zone of yeah
okay we go just just one game week 18
well what happens if the ravens play a
team in a few weeks who has an outbreak
now they have to make two games up or
whatever uh scary and you know i i'll
still say this i feel bad for the
steelers there you are 10-0 here's
another hey screw you we're gonna change
the schedule i know you guys have done
everything right and i know they'll be
ready to play and i have no excuses but
uh it's just it's unbelievable what
they've had to go through this year with
first the tennessee titans and now this
and that they're still 10-0 and and
doing well that says a lot to mike
tomlin and his leadership
well and if they get on the field
tomorrow night it's going to be 11 and i
would be stunned stunned of course i've
been stunned several times already this
year but i would be beyond stunned if
the ravens find a way to win that game
after everything they've been through
and with so many players not available
from lamar jackson to mark andrews to
willie snead to matthew jude onto this
guy that guy that guy all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports